[Musique]
vous voyez encore assez claire marie
pour broder âge je bois mais quand je
fais quelques heures routages ça diminue
il y a quand même des destins qui
doivent être plus difficile que les
autres a avoué y en a qui sont beaucoup
plus chargé la queue loïc doigts et la
coiffe ici par exemple beaucoup plus
difficiles comme vous même vous faites
vos dessins vous essayez de les faire
qui peuvent convenir votre au travail
que oui mais on peut pas toujours non
plus parce que la forme de la coiffe
exige que toi aussi les fleurs bien sûr
les mettre n'importe quelle fleur il
faut que ça convient puisqu'il ya la
largeur il ya aussi la hauteur je n'ai
jamais vu ce dessin là ce que vous même
s'il avait fait c'est un nouveau dessin
oui vous avez fait win
alors là il est presque finie suis là et
je vais le découper non seul membre de
the artist également mais il faut
découper et le tissu de sous ça c'est de
l'organdi il ya plutôt des noms me tue
le depuis presque depuis la guerre on
n'en fait plus beaucoup
où avez-vous appris votre métier mari
j'ai appris mon métier ou pas loin de
chez moi minéraux
c'est une demoiselle gréhaigne quel âge
aviez-vous mari j'avais
pas tout à fait 14 ans j'ai quitté
l'école en juillet tango vacances et je
vais 14 ans en novembre et qui à petits
coups après on se tait décoiffe
quand on avait presque fini trois
métiers combien de temps reste et vous
l'apprentissage se fait 18 morts 18 mois
oui et après ça vous avez travaillé chez
vous après j'ai fait un peu chez moi
oui et j'ai fait aussi comme les autres
on faisait juste l'hiver et on faisait
la saison aussi l usine l usine ont
travaillé les plus pour vous et c'était
de meilleurs rapports certainement que
deux modèles soit rien arrivé
et après alors l'idée en refuser la prod
rit oui combien de temps marie
mettez-vous pour faire tout cela pour
faire la coiffe jeu mais à peu près
trois semaines sans oui il faut bien le
dire et je suis en train de finir une
paire de lacets pour la coiffe que je
fais tu ici à et seniors le mariage de
votre petite fille joue pleinement les
mariages de ma petite fille maintenant
le c'est moi qui réponds tu mets quoi
vous êtes de repasseuse de coiffes
non je ne suis pas vrai passeuse de
coiffes je fais ici puisque vous voyez
je repasse décoiffe
ce soit mais de médecine ont alors
commencé des choses se présentent elles
au départ la coiffe n'est pas ronde au
départ la coiffe des parents et les
plates et les plats vous voyez est alors
que fait-on avant de de passer le faire
sous la selle à quoi je crois que l'avis
donné oui que peut vous montrer comment
jamie donne la coiffe
y at-il dans dans l'amidon de l'amidon
de l'eau oui c'est tout vous ne pouvez
pas autre chose la bougie jeu mais pour
faire à la coiffe un briller un peu
entre sa oui oui mais au fond c'est
patrick et ça c'est pas pour la douce
douce durcir non et après on fait le
mélange le mélange avec bleu l'amidon
cuit on met du cru oui et c'est ça qui
fait durcir la cua mais non je vais vous
montrer comment on la repasse il faut un
air très chaud
autrement ça c'est pas assez dur pour
que la fin du passage toute l'humilité
de la vie dont et disparus vous voyez
lurcy mais n'est pas encore assez je
n'ai pas encore si vous n'avez pas une
eau à côté du goulag qui est un petit
peu plus durs au monde
si je peux laisser c'est là où vous
voyez il vous montre celle-ci alors cela
vous devez déjà passé selon elle est
déjà repassé elle est totalement seul
elle est au nom change rigide mis un peu
d'eau tu fais bull a exactement
eh ben pour dessécher les bigoudènes
c'est ça qui se nomme la bigoudène vous
voyez oui oui et ça c'est le sommet de
la fois et bien c'est ça qui tient la
coiffe
quand je dis chiche les quoi je mets
tout mon temps de sécher une ou deux
comme ça dépend des coiffes que j'ai si
c'est une demi journée et le lendemain
je l' ai fini alors je mets moins
longtemps l'eau vous voyez je finissais
là cela vous l'avez que vous aviez
commencé girl aussi celle là elle est
commencée hier le fond c'est très long
donc c'est très longue c'est très long
bien sûr là la coiffe est là elle est
entièrement faux pour lui cela est fini
j'avais fini ya plus même temps que la
même que la mecque sur la tête sur la
tête avec le petit bonhomme vega et puis
les lacets c'est ça vous voyez là c'est
ici j'ai l'impression puis la saison
beaucoup plus souple que la coiffe ce
n'est pas du tout l'âme à la même
manière de repasser c'est moi à me
donner c'est moins à me donner c'était
par l'ami donc cru ça parce qu'il ya un
tout petit peu d'amis dont on met pas
beaucoup parce que le lhc doit flotter
un peu au vent et ben voui voui sa
flotte
j'avais
il
mon
[Musique]